welcome to cbs this morning where a lot
of people are still dreaming it's so
interesting that
mlk's birthday and celebrating his life
comes on this particular week after all
that's going on in this country we need
a reminder
of who we really are i think that is the
question before us who are we
is that why are we is a question
everybody's asking well we're going to
begin with that question because america
is just
two days away from the inauguration but
the mood in washington
you could say is tense very tense it
looks like a military zone
near the capitol with tall fencing and
up to 25
thousand national guard troops expected
by wednesday
the national mall and many streets are
closed amid concerns about the potential
domestic terror threat
from right-wing extremists a new cbs
news poll includes a startling figure
54 percent of americans say the biggest
threat to america's way of life
is other people in america jeff begays
is inside a restricted area of
washington jeff good morning morning
anthony two days out from the
inauguration and
security is locking down here and that
includes the vetting
of the security force that is in place
here this is a
massive security force make no mistake
about that
and what it has done is essentially sent
the message to the public
don't come down here you know why if you
look behind me you can see why
businesses are boarded up all over this
place
and the streets are shut down
new video published by the new yorker
shows rioters pouring through a window
into a hallway of the capitol on january
6. there they told police why they say
they were in the building
they eventually gained access to the
senate chamber
some were searching for lawmakers
on the senate floor they rifled through
papers looking for any valuable
information
i think crews would want us to do this
so yeah absolutely i think we're good
and posed for photos i love you guys
you're brothers but
we can't be disrespectful don't
disrespect them they can steal an
election when kids in their chairs
no seen in the video is air force
veteran larry brock
who is carrying plastic zip ties that
can function as makeshift handcuffs
brock has been charged with knowingly
entering or remaining in a restricted
building
and violent entry and disorderly conduct
on capitol grounds
brock is one of at least 22 current or
former members of the u.s military or
law enforcement who've been
identified as being at or near the riot
that's according to the associated press
which also reports the defense officials
fear of possible
inside attack at the inauguration david
martin has asked general daniel
hawkinson the chief of the national
guard bureau about any internal concerns
are you worried at all about the
reliability
of your national guard troops absolutely
not have you been screening some of the
troops
as they come in yes sir in coordination
with the secret service and the fbi
they're screening all the personnel that
are coming in
the national guard troops answer to the
commander-in-chief who until
wednesday at noon will still be
president trump
on 60 minutes last night scott pelley
asked acting deputy secretary of
homeland security ken cuccinelli
what they would do if mr trump asked
them to stand
down we're going to complete our jobs
there's not a there's not a stand down
we have a statutory mission we're going
to perform under all circumstances and i
think that hypothetical is
not going to happen it's unimaginable
what was unimaginable just a few weeks
ago is
this level of security to cover an
inauguration in this country however
the prospect of fellow americans
threatening violence against other
americans
that's what has brought this on and
that's where we stand now
tony as scott said last night on 60
minutes there's a lot that's
unimaginable right now in washington dc
jeff thank you very much